for many years financial markets have
been regulated in terms of the amount of
interest that can be charged on loans
and the types of securities that can be
offered by different entities where
their loans have collateral or not all
of those things are heavily regulated in
China and this has led to what's called
the shadow banking system where there
are billions and billions of dollars
being lent out through non-bank
institutions to make business possible
where the supply of regulated credit is
insufficient China wants to regularize
this shadow banking industry wants to
bring it into the formal sector but to
do that they're going to have to slowly
start to liberalize these other
regulations that have been constraining
that sector and this could be quite a
disruptive process because every time
they liberalize one of the asset classes
a certain type of loan or security all
of the returns on that asset class will
change and there will be shifts in where
credit is available in the market this
is part of their overall economic reform
plan it's part of what they're seeking
to do to open up their capital markets
further to make their currency a
convertible currency that can be used
freely in international markets and move
across its borders freely but it's going
to take time and it will have
disruptions along the way